PROFESSOR: I think you
will get going.
A lot of people are not here,
but I think if the MRS meeting
were going on across the river
I would be there too if I
didn't have a class to go to.
We had last time finished
a discussion strain.
And we introduced strain by
defining it as a displacement,
each component of a vector
displacement U as being given
by a set of coefficients, eij
times x of j, which says that
the displacement in a deformed
body varies linearly with the
position of the particular
point in the body.
We could also express the
same thing in terms
of change of length.
The change in the vector U would
be given by-- we show
the same set of coefficients--
eij times delta x of j.
So whether you want the
displacement vector or you
want the fractional change of
length, you get this by an
expression of the same sort.
We saw though that unless we
define the coefficients
correctly we could have a
situation where a body is not
only deformed but is
rotated as well.
And we saw that in general
unless we define these
coefficients carefully we would
include in this tensor a
component of pure rotation,
rigid body rotation.
And this would not measure
deformation.
However, regardless of its
suitability or unsuitability,
the positional vector
is a vector.
It transforms like a vector.
The displacement U is a vector,
and it will transform
like a vector; ergo, the 3 by
3 array eij is a second-rank
tensor and we'll transform
like a tensor.
We showed though that we could
take eij and get rid of the
pure rotation that might
be contained in those
coefficients by writing it as
a tensor epsilon ij plus
another tensor omega ij.
And that was a new wrinkle,
the concept of adding two
tensors together to get
a third tensor.
We did run into that before.
And we define the elements of
the two tensors epsilon and
omega; epsilon ij was given by
one half of eij plus eji, and
omega ij is given by one
half of omega ij.
And notice the order of the
subscripts here in this
difference.
That is a matter of definition,
but it defines
which term is omega ij
and which is omega
ji minus omega ji.
I'm sorry.
This should be eij minus eji.
And we showed that at a tensor
of this form which would have
all of the diagonal terms zero
and the off-diagonal terms
equal to the negative of one
another that a tensor of this
form does indeed correspond
to pure body rotation.
We showed that by looking at
a point at the end of a
positional vector U and looked
at a displacement which would
be exactly at right
angles to it.
And the U would be given
by the tensor relation.
We showed that U dot r is
identically zero when the
displacement vector is given by
this tensor with diagonal
term zero and the off-diagonal
terms equal to the negative of
one another.
So we have then from a general
tensor of the form eij
constructed in the terms epsilon
ij something that is a
measure of true deformation.
It is a symmetric tensor
by definition.
And therefore in addition to all
of the other properties of
second-rank tensor, namely
having a law of transformation
and staying symmetric for any
arbitrary change of coordinate
systems, the radius normal
property also works.
Hence, the representation
surface that we construct from
the tensor epsilon ij xi
xj equals 1, gives
us the strain quadric.
And it has the property that the
radius gives us the value
of strain in a given
direction.
And the value of the radius
literally is going to be the
vector that's on the left hand
side, the magnitude of U times
the component of U that is
parallel to the radial vector
per unit radial vector.
And this then is the tensile
strain, the fractional change
of length as we look
in this direction.
The radius normal is going to
give us the direction of the
total displacement U. And the
value of the property in that
direction is going to be the
product of that displacement
with a unit vector in the
direction of interest.
And therefore that is the
tensile strain as we said
before from the general
properties of the quadric.
So everything we said about
second-rank tensor and in
particular symmetric tensor
holds for the strain tensor.
We can talk about diagonalizing
the strain
tensor into a form epsilon 1,
1, epsilon 22, zero zero,
epsilon 33.
And I'll remind you that we know
how to do this to set up
the normal equations and solve
for the eigenvalues and then
look for the principal
axes of a tensor.
There are special forms
of the strain tensor.
Something that 1 diagonal
goes into this form is
called plane strain.
And I love the melodic nature
of that, the plane strain.
If this were strain induced by
a Modernistic transformation,
we could call it the
Bain plane strain.
If we diagonalized it,
it would be the
main Bain plane strains.
And if that deformation took
place in an aircraft window,
we could call it the plane-pane
main Bain strains.
And we could continue on
indefinitely, but I think
you're finding this tiresome.
Another form of the strain
tensor that doesn't look what
it actually represents is
epsilon 1 zero minus epsilon 1
zero zero zero zero.
That looks peculiar,
very special.
But, again, this is analogous
to what we found for stress.
If we rotate this tensor 45
degrees, we would find that
treat tensor was diagonally,
had all the
diagonal elements zero.
And we would have the
epsilon 11 prime--
let's just call it
epsilon prime--
and this epsilon prime
zero zero zero.
And this is pure shear
Something that we'll show
shortly, and in fact I left it
to you as a problem
on a problems set.
The sum of the diagonal
elements, epsilon 11 plus
epsilon 22 plus epsilon 33 is
something that's defined as
the trace of the tensor.
And for the strain tensor, the
trace turns out to be equal to
delta V over the fractional
change in volume.
And we'll show that in just
a little bit as well.
So a characteristic of pure
shear is that it does not
result in any change of
volume of the solid.
There's deformation, but the
volume stays exactly the same.
Let me then proceed to show that
the trace of the strain
tensor is indeed the
change in volume.
And want I'll do is to look at
an element of volume that is
oriented along the principal
elements of strain.
So if this as x1, this is x2,
and this is x3, the strain
tensor I'll assume
is oriented.
So we have a term epsilon 11
zero zero zero zero; epsilon
22 zero zero zero; epsilon 33.
So let's suppose that the solid
originally has edges L1,
L2, and L3 along x1, x2,
and x3, respectively.
So the initial volume before any
deformation will be simply
L1 times L2 times L3.
Let's suppose now we impose
the strain, and the volume
then we'll increase to some
value of V plus delta V. And
the length L1 will change
to a value L1 times 1
plus epsilon 11.
That is to say it'll be L1
plus epsilon 11 times L1,
which can be factored
out in this fashion.
L2 changes to L2 times
1 plus epsilon 22.
And L3 changes to L3 plus
epsilon 33 times L3, which
I'll write in this fashion.
So expanding this product,
it'll be L1, L2, L3.
And then if I simply multiply
out these terms, I'll have 1,
and then I'll have epsilon 11
plus epsilon 22 plus epsilon
11 times epsilon 22.
And this will be times
1 plus epsilon 33.
And if I carry out that
multiplication,
that will be 1 plus--
and I'll get exactly these terms
again-- epsilon 11 plus
epsilon 22 plus epsilon
11 times epsilon 22.
And then a term epsilon 33 plus
epsilon 11 epsilon 33
plus epsilon 22 times
epsilon 33.
And then a third-order term,
epsilon 11 times epsilon 22
times epsilon 33.
Now having gone through the
painful process of expanding
that, I will proceed to say that
the epsilons are always
going to be very small.
Elastic strains are typically
on the order of 10
to the minus 6.
So a product of two of those
strains is 10 to the minus 12.
And a product of three of those
terms is going to be on
the order of 10 to
the minus 18.
So this last term is going
to be minuscule.
And now I use a higher order
term intentionally rather than
a higher rank term.
This is really a term
of higher order.
The same is true of all the
peer-wise projects of this
[INAUDIBLE].
So I now have left if I turn out
these higher order terms
to pasture, I'll have 1 plus
epsilon 11 plus epsilon 22
plus epsilon 33.
And the rest is negligible.
And this will be the original
volume V times 1 plus epsilon
11 plus epsilon 22
plus epsilon 33.
So delta V over V, if I subtract
off V on the left,
delta V over V then is simply
going to be equal to epsilon
11 plus epsilon 22
plus epsilon 33.
So this is indeed the fractional
change of volume,
and it's the trace
of epsilon ij.
Now, physically, you wouldn't
expect the volume to change if
I change my reference
axes because
that's a scalar quantity.
So I've shown by a hand-waving,
backdoor argument
that in fact the trace of a
tensor does stay invariant for
at least this particular
tensor.
But it's fairly straightforward
to show that
for any tensor aij the trace
of the tensor is invariant
when you change the
coordinate system.
And that's not hard to do.
If you're clever, it takes
about three lines.
So I'll invite you to the
exhilaration of discovering
that for yourself on
a problem set.
Any questions or comments?
All right.
Having defined strain as a
symmetric second-rank tensor
when we factor out rigid body
rotation, we can view strain
as a physical property.
And I think I tried to hoodwink
you last time by
saying this is a property
of material.
So therefore strain tensor has
to also conform to all of the
symmetry restrains that
we have derived very
exhaustively.
And you said, no, no, no, no,
that can't be; I don't believe
that I can only give a uniform
uniaxial deformation to an
orthorhombic crystal.
And I say, yeah, but to get the
deformation, you have to
squeeze the crystal.
And that is going to be linked
to the deformation by the
elastic constants, and they
are physical properties.
And that maybe makes you
think a little bit.
But actually even though
operationally you impose a
strain by imposing a stress or
by doing something else to the
crystal that results in a
strain, you can nevertheless
pick any stimulus you
wish to achieve a
desired state of strain.
So there is no symmetry
constraint on the form of the
strain tensor that can result.
So the stain tensor then is
not a property tensor.
It is also a field tensor
just like stress.
So it can have any form we
choose to create in it.
So we now have the potential
of having
stress as a field tensor.
And we have strain as
a field tensor.
And within limits, we can create
strains of these two
field tensors of any
form that we wish.
And we can now regard these as
things that we do to crystals
and look at a whole range of
properties that result when
the generalized force is not
a vector, a tensor of first
rank, but the generalized
force is a--
let's say-- a stress tensor.
It's a generalized force
which itself is not
a first rank tensor.
It's a second rank tensor.
So we'll see a whole collection
of interesting
properties that fall
into this category.
But first I'd like to look at
one remaining second-rank
tensor property, and that
is thermal expansion.
And this is a curious
second-rank tensor property,
and we couldn't discuss
it until we had
talked about strain.
And let me introduce it by
one-dimensional example.
Let's suppose we have a rodlike
specimen of length L.
And let's suppose it is
in equilibrium at some
temperature T. And then we heat
it up to some temperature
T plus delta T.
In response to that particular
change in temperature, the
length of the rod will increase
to a length L plus
delta L. It expands.
And we would find experimentally
that delta L,
first of all, is proportional
to L. If you make the rod
twice as long, the amount of
expansion in an absolute sense
is twice as large.
And secondly, provided you're
well above very, very low
temperatures, close to absolute
zero, delta L will
also be proportional to the
change in temperature.
Thermal expansion is one of
those properties which
thermodynamically must
go to zero as
temperature goes to zero.
So the thermal expansion
coefficient that we've yet to
define will be a function of
temperature as we get down to
very low temperatures on the
order of a few degrees Kelvin.
So we can define then the
linear thermal expansion
coefficient for this rod as 1
over L, delta L over delta T.
So this is something that will
give us the fractional change
of lengths.
And what we can do now in
general is to say that if we
create a general strain, not
a tensile strain, we have a
general strain epsilon 11 plus
epsilon 12, epsilon 13, and so
on, has to be symmetric.
So epsilon 21 is equal
to epsilon 12.
We'll say that this tensor
epsilon ij will be written in
general for the
three-dimensional case as a
second-rank tensor aij times
a scalar quantity delta T.
The strain is the
field tensor.
That's the response.
The stimulus that creates this
response is an incremental
change in temperature.
But as this is a second-rank
tensor and this is a scalar,
an array of coefficients in
which we multiply every
element of a tensor by a scalar
is also a tensor.
So this is called the
linear thermal
expansion coefficient tensor.
And it is a symmetric tensor by
definition since a measure
of true strain is by definition
a symmetric tensor.
So this is the linear thermal
expansion coefficient tensor.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
temperature gradient
[INAUDIBLE]
and talk about the
directionality say between
here and here because of the
temperature [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Sure.
Sure if you wanted to do that.
That assumes that the thermal
conductivity would be very
small so that the temperature
inside the body would not
attempt to [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
In the same way that you could
create strains that are in
homogeneous as well.
We'll now for the first time
start talking not in terms of
abstractions but in terms of
some real physical properties.
What is the range of
linear thermal
expansion coefficient tensors?
And unlike many physical
properties, that's an easy one
to answer, 10 to the minus
6 degree C per degree C.
Materials have a very, very
small range linear thermal
expansion coefficients.
And let me give you some
examples for real materials.
They go up to maybe 10 to the
minus 5 for a very soft weakly
bonded materials.
But the for metals--
and I'm giving you a single
number now because these are
averages for polycrystalline
materials--
the value of A times
10 to the 6.
For lead, a low- melting metal,
is 28, 2.8 times 10 to
the minus 5.
For copper, 18.
For iron, 12.
Four tungsten, a very
refractory metal, 5.
And for diamond, a very strongly
bonded materials,
it's 0.89 times 10 minus 6.
If we look at compounds, again,
the average linear
thermal expansion coefficient
times 10 to the 6 for
polycrystalline material.
For aluminum bromide, hardly
a technology material of
commerce, but in light of this
because this has one of the
largest linear thermal expansion
coefficients of any
material, very weakly
bonded to compound.
For a more typical ionic
compound, NaCL, 40 times 10 to
the minus 6.
For calcium fluoride, this has
a bivalent cation in it, so
the material is stronger, more
strongly bonded, 20.
For MgO, both a divalent cation
and the divalent anion,
as you would expect, the thermal
expansion coefficient
drop still more.
For Al2O3, a trivalent cation
that goes down to 8.8, and
that's really an average
because this
is a hexagonal material.
And a second-rank property
tensor for a hexagonal crystal
has to have two equal diagonal
elements and one independent
diagonal element when you
diagonalize the tensor.
Spinal, MgAl2O4 this is
representative of all of the
ferrites for example, 7.6.
Silicon carbide, a
very refractory
covalent compound, 4.7.
For glasses, here's
a surprise.
You might think that a glass
might have about the same
linear expansion coefficient as
the crystalline form of the
same composition.
But a sodium calcium silicon
oxide glass, so called
soda-lime silicate glass,
is 9, fairly low.
A borosilicate glass, like the
Vicor that we love to make
glass apparatus out of, 4.5.
And one of the near record
holder is fused silica,
silicio glass, and here
a measly value of 0.5.
So glasses have very low linear
thermal expansion
coefficients compared to
crystallize materials that are
predominantly ionic.
And the reason lies in the
nature of the structure.
Something like MgO has ordered
ions, and when you heat it up,
it expands isotropically.
A glass is this random network
of edge-shared polyhedra.
So when you heat it up, yes,
the dimensions of the
polyhedra increase in proportion
to the change of
temperature.
But the framework because it's
so meandering and open can
buckle to accommodate the
increased size of the
tetrahedra that are
in the linkage.
So the result is the network
buckles, but the overall
microscopic thermal expansion
is very, very slight even
though the tetrahedra are
changing dimensions in the
same degree that they are in
these crystalline inorganic
nonmetallic materials.
Let me give you a handout not
that it's up to date, but
there was a very nice,
convenient one-page article in
the Journal of the American
Ceramic Society a number of
years ago that lists thermal
expansion coefficients for low
expansion oxides.
So let me pass that around
and let you take off
for copy with that.
And that gives some examples of
the value of this property
for, again, for polycrystalline
materials,
which if you looked at a single
crystal would show
anisotropy.
And here you'll find a few
materials in the list near the
top they're arranged in order
of increasing linear thermal
expansion, you'll find some that
are just about zero when
you have a polycrystalline
form of the material.
And you'll have some that have
this very unusual behavior
where the linear thermal
expansion coefficient is
actually negative.
So let me pass this around
for reference.
Now this may seem to be a
curiosity that you can fine
for a polycrystalline material
for which the individual
grains expand anisotropically
a bulk linear thermal
expansion coefficient of zero.
Why should one care other than
that being a curious result?
Can anybody guess?
AUDIENCE: Can you
say that again?
PROFESSOR: That these are
materials which in a
polycrystalline form with random
grain orientation have
a linear thermal expansion
coefficient this is
essentially zero?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Exactly.
The materials out of which you
build furnace linings and
tanks for melting glass or
smelting steel have to be made
out of polycrystalline
materials.
You can't have a monolithic
single crystal that's large
enough to melt a significant
amount of
glass in for example.
And being polycrystalline, when
the material expands,
there is a great deal of stress
between neighboring
grains because they're
randomly oriented.
If the bulk microscopic thermal
expansion coefficient
is zero, that is going to be
refractory that is very, very
resistant to thermal shock.
When you heat it up, you don't
find intergranular cracking.
So the materials that have
essentially zero spatially
average thermal expansion
coefficients are very
attractive for refractories.
You can pick up any issue
of the Journal of
the American Ceramics--
not the journal, but the
Bulletin of the American
Ceramic Society and you will
find refractory companies
hustling materials like
Cordierite, which is a
silicate material that on
average has one positive
thermal expansion coefficient,
one negative thermal expansion
coefficient.
And the volume change of the
individual grains is
essentially zero.
So that makes a dandy material
for refractories.
Cordierite has another
interesting property that is a
really nice example
of anisotropy
of a physical property.
If I ask you to rattle off some
properties which you know
to be very anisotropic, one of
them that you wouldn't think
of is color.
Your t-shirt is pink,
so how can that be
a function of direction?
Well your t-shirt is not
a single crystal.
And their single crystals which
if you hold them up to
light and pass through a plain
polarized beam of light the
crystal has a very different
color for one direction of
polarization then another.
And these colors, interestingly,
very often are
strikingly different.
They're crystals that are green
in light polarized in
one direction and red for
light polarized in the
opposite direction.
And there is in the old
Icelandic sagas--
few people have heard of them.
The Icelandic sagas which were
written in about the year 500
are one of the early forms of
Western literature that is
really great, enduring
world-class literature.
In the sagas, there's one
episode where Thor is sleeping
and Olaf comes along and
steals his sunstone.
And Thor is upset he takes
his battle as and cut
Olaf's head in twain.
And people puzzled
for hundreds of
years, what is sunstone.
This doesn't compute
in today's age.
And finally a Norwegian
archaeologist came up with a
hypothesis that in Iceland there
are remarkably large and
remarkably transparent and
perfect single crystals of
Cordierite.
And Cordierite is strikingly
pleochroic.
That's color that is a function
of direction.
And what this archaeologist
theorized is that the Vikings
would take a sunstone when they
went sailing on the North
Sea, which is notoriously damp
and overcast and gray, and
your principal means of
navigation was the sun.
But when the sky was overcast,
you couldn't see the sun.
But the sun as it comes through
the cloud gives you
light that's very strongly
polarized.
So the theory is that the
Vikings would have very
perfect crystals of transparent
Cordierite, would
hold them up to the sky, and
turn them around until the
Cordierite crystal lit up a
bright, golden sunny yellow.
What better name for
the sunstone.
You found the sun from the
direction of polarization of
the light scattered from the
cloud when you've got the
crystal oriented just so.
In a different orientation, it
would look murkier, look sort
of a bluish purple for the other
principal direction of
the birefringence.
So there is putting crystal
anisotropy hundreds of years
ago to a very useful purpose
to navigate on cloudy days.
Unfortunately, the Vikings
used it to sail down the
British coast and sacked
the next village.
So it shows you that even the
most simple of science can be
put to application
in war research.
Anyway, won't go
there anymore.
So index of refraction and color
can also be a strong
function of direction
The numbers that I put on the
blackboard suggest that the
magnitude of thermal expansion
coefficients are influenced
very strongly by the strength
of the interatomic bonding.
And this shows up in a very,
very striking way if you group
together classes of comparable
materials.
And if you plot the value of the
linear thermal expansion
coefficient in units of 10 to
the minus 6 per degree C as a
function of the melting point in
degrees Kelvin, the numbers
range from about 400 K for
materials like sulfur up to
about 3,700 for tungsten.
And the variation is
so beautiful it
could make you cry.
It goes as the inverse
of the melting point.
And way up here are materials
like for sulfur and lithium.
And the way out here are
materials like tungsten.
And their relation is given
by a equals 0.020 over the
melting point in
degrees Kelvin.
So very strong correlation
between melting point and
linear expansion for
simple elements.
If you do the same thing for
compounds, you find a similar
parabolic relation except
it is offset.
For oxides and halides, many
of them with the rock salt
structure, so they
are isotropic.
And again, if you plot here the
melting point in degrees
Kelvin, the numbers here
range up to 60 times 10
to the minus 6.
And again, a variation
with 1 over T, but
offset from the origin.
And the curve here is that a
equals 0.038 over T, the
melting point T sub m in Kelvin,
minus 7.0 times 10 to
the minus 6.
Finally, let me finish with some
data for single crystals
that provide examples
of and anisotropy.
These are all hexagonal
materials.
And I will give you the--
not all hexagonal.
I take that back.
But they're all uniaxial
crystals.
The value of the thermal
expansion coefficient along C
and the thermal expansion
coefficient that is parallel
to C, so these are the elements
that would be in the
diagonal isothermal
expansion tensor.
So for Al2O3, which is a
hexagonal rhombohedral oxide,
the two expansion coefficients
are 8.39 and 9.0 times 10 to
the minus 6, not terribly
anisotropic.
But the structure of alumina is
a close-packed arrangement
of oxygen with aluminum filling
2/3 of the available
octahedral holes.
So it's hexagonal only because
of the sites that are filled
in the array.
For TiO2, which is [INAUDIBLE]
and therefore also uniaxial,
6.8 perpendicular to C; 8.3
parallel to C. For zirconium
silicate, 3.7 and 6.2, almost
a 2:1 difference.
For the quartz form of silica,
which is hexagonal, 14
perpendicular to C;
9 parallel to C.
For carbon, the graphite form,
a layer structure--
you can almost guess how this
is going to turn out.
It's going to be humongous
perpendicular to the lawyers
and very small within the plane
of these tightly bonded
hexagonal nets.
And that is indeed the case,
1 perpendicular to C; 27
parallel to C. So there is an
anisotropy of a factor of 27.
A few more.
Aluminum titanate, perpendicular
to C minus 2.6;
parallel to C 11.5.
A very well known example
of anisotropy, extreme
anisotropy, where one principal
coefficient is
positive and two are negative
is the calcite forms calcium
carbonate, minus 6 and 25.
For zinc metal, a hexagonal
close-packed metal, surprising
degree of anisotropy,
14 and 64.
And for tellurium, which is a
chain structure like selenium,
27 perpendicular to C and
minus 1.6 in a direction
parallel to C.
Even simple hexagonal
close-packed metals can do
strange things at low
temperatures.
For zinc, the expansion
coefficients perpendicular to
C and parallel to C as a
function of temperature go at
300 degrees C from 13 and 64.
At 150, the values have
dropped to 8 and 65.
At 60 degrees K perpendicular to
C, the thermal expansion is
negative and has not dropped
terribly much of at all
parallel to C. So this is
a hexagonal close-packed
structure lot.
A lot of action and strange
things going on in the plane
at the close-packed layers, but
not very much change in a
direction perpendicular
to the layers.
Let me raise one more issue.
If we were to look at some of
these strangely anisotropic
materials which had negative
thermal expansion coefficients
in one direction and positive
in another, what would the
representation quadric
look like?
Suppose we looked at calcite,
for example, which has a large
negative thermal expansion
coefficient.
And if we look at the thermal
expansion quadric when the
tensor was referred
to the principal
axes, parallel to C--
well, the thermal expansion
tensor aij along its principal
axes would be along A1 in a
direction perpendicular to C,
it would be for the data given
here, minus 6, zero, zero,
zero, minus 6, zero,
zero, zero.
And A33 is 25.
So that's very, very
anisotropic.
But what is this going to be?
This is going to be a quadric
that has the shape of an
hyperboloid of two sheets.
So it's going to
look like this.
And there'll be an asymptote
like this and then
asymptote like this.
Along the asymptote,
the radius of
the quadric is infinite.
So therefore along these
directions the
strain is equal to zero.
Strain goes as 1 over
the radius squared.
In this range of directions
here, the radius is imaginary.
But remember that the
strain is given by 1
over the radius squared.
So this says that the strain is
negative, so the material
has contracted.
And finally, in this range of
directions where the radius is
finite and positive, if the
value of strain is 1 over
radius squared, this says that
the maximum deformation is
along the direction of the C
axis, and it's positive.
The material expands along C;
the minimum radius of the
quadric corresponds to the
maximum thermal expansion.
So let me close with
a question.
Along the asymptote of the
quadric, the strain is zero.
Does this mean that this
direction in a crystal of
calcite does not move, no
deformation at all when you
heat it up?
I see faint shakes
of the head.
I don't know if that's just in
awe of what's going on here or
an opinion on the question.
Do you think it'll
be no strain?
AUDIENCE: It would
be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good answer.
Let's remember a property of
the representation quadric.
The direction of what happens
is normal to the surface of
the quadric.
The thing that is happening here
is the displacement; ui
is given by epsilon
ij times U sub j.
So when we look in this
direction, the displacement,
which would be normal to the
surface of the quadric, gives
us this as a displacement.
So along the asymptotes of the
quadric, you can't say that
there's no deformation, but
that the deformation
corresponds to pure rotation
and not any
fractional change of length.
In these directions, the length
changes, but it is a
decrease in length within
the asymptotes.
For those directions, the
strain is an extension.
And again, if you want to know
the direction of the
displacement, you find the
normal to the surface of the
quadric in the direction of
interest, and that's the
direction in which the
radius vector points.
All right.
That's I think a good
place to quit.
I think I'll say a little bit
more after the break about the
atomistic reason for increases
in interionic separations,
which we can get some insight
into from a simple model.
But before we disperse, I don't
know if everybody got a
copy of problem set 13.
If anybody didn't, there's some
extra copies up here.
But I will with great pleasure
pass out to you problems set
number 14, which has served
two purposes.
One is to have you show for
yourself that the trace of a
second-rank tensor--
I called it second-order
tensor--
second-rank tensor the sum of
the diagonal elements is
invariant for a change of
reference axes for a general
direction cosine scheme for
the change of axes.
And then the other two questions
are to give you some
practice in diagonalizing a
second-rank property tensor
which is not in diagonal form.
And I asked you to do
this in two ways.
One is by direct solution of
the secular equation and
finding the eigenvectors.
And then the third example,
which is for a completely
general tensor, to do this by
the method of successive
approximations.
And you'll find after a couple
of iterations you get fairly
close to convergence.
So I shall pass this around.
And again, I think there's
something to be
learned from that.
Let's take our stretch then.
I'm sure that lecture involved
a lot of stress and strain.
Ha, ha.
Let's resume in 10 minutes.
And we'll then move on to some
additional higher rank tensor
properties, which will be
very, very interesting.
Go for it.